die gen scheren kirst barkasse 9 wird
schon seit längerer zeit als superstar
der biologie gefeiert bisher war es
jedoch nur ein großer wunschtraum mit
dieser technologie krankheiten zu heilen
und menschenleben zu retten doch jetzt
ist der erste schritt getan denn
us-mediziner medizinerin haben zwei
krebspatienten im endstadium mit dieser
technik behandelt zusätzliche gene
sollen ihre immunzellen dabei
unterstützen den aggressiven krebs im
körper zu bekämpfen
krieg zum tanzen fiction jetzt täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst wenn nichts
herzlich willkommen christa karas neue
methode ist also jetzt aus den laboren
in die kliniken dieser welt entlassen
worden in einer renommierten
fachzeitschrift wurde dieser versuch
allerdings noch nicht veröffentlicht die
sensationsmeldung kommt von dem us
radiosender national public radio npr
demnach sollen zwei patienten an der
university of pennsylvania mit der
genscher christa kassen neuen behandelt
worden sein einer der beiden ist an der
seltenen krebsart multiples myelom
erkrankt wobei die weißen zellen der
immunabwehr betroffen sind der andere
patient leidet an einen sack home also
einem bösartigen tumor der in
weichgewebe und knochen vorkommen
gängige therapieversuche waren bei
beiden patienten erfolglos verlaufen und
so wurde den meldungen zufolge die
sogenannte eben chris packers neuen
technologie kurz chris bahn gewandt
darüber hatten wir ja hier bei pixum
schon immer wieder mal berichtet die
methode revolutioniert gerade die
gentechnik denn mit ihrer hilfe lassen
sich ausgewählte gene einfügen
ausschalten oder auch umschalten und
zwar sehr einfach es funktioniert quasi
so simpel wie eine schere nur es ist
nicht exakt aber mit ihr kann die dna
also das erbgut ziemlich effektiv
verändert werden bei der behandlung der
beiden us krebspatienten mit der gewehre
wurden sogenannte t zellen also mut
zellen entnommen und diese dann im labor
genetisch verändert diese modifizierten
zellen werden dann wieder in den körper
der patienten eingesetzt und sollen
dabei helfen die krebszellen zu
zerstören das ziel ist es also die
immunabwehr der betroffenen aufzurüsten
damit der körpereigene kampf gegen die
krebszellen unterstützt werden kann
diese behandlung wird finanziert durch
das immun therapiezentrum institute for
cancer in monotherapie in san francisco
und einem us-unternehmen für
biotherapeutika sie erfolgt im rahmen
einer kurzstudie des
krebsforschungszentrums abbremsen cancer
center die untersuchung in den usa ist
bisher auf 18 patienten beschränkt wie
erfolgversprechend die fachleute selbst
ihr vorhaben einschätzen ist bislang
nicht bekannt dazu eine sprecherin der
university of pennsylvania
forschungsergebnisse werden zu einem
angemessenen zeitpunkt bei einer
vorstellung oder in einer
fachzeitschrift mitgeteilt werden
doch im großen und ganzen rechnet ein
teil der fachwelt schon in absehbarer
zeit mit einem entscheidenden durchbruch
zum beispielsweise der us genforscher
förder uhr noch in einem interview mit
mpi 2009 10 ist das jahr in dem die
stützräder wegfallen und die welt zu
sehen bekommt was chris barth im
positivsten sinne bewirken kann
bisher gab es nur vereinzelt versuche
mit christa krankheiten zu heilen ein
großteil von ihnen wurde in china
durchgeführt und zielte auf die
behandlung verschiedener krebsarten ab
doch fest steht auch dass die zahl der
kritiker groß ist schließlich sind die
langzeitfolgen derzeit alles andere als
absehbar zudem sind viele ethische
fragen noch nicht geklärt wie kann
beispielsweise ausgeschlossen werden
dass diese technik missbraucht wird und
wie können möglicherweise schädliche
nebenwirkungen ausgeschlossen werden
dazu die medizinethikerin horizont es
könnte klappen es könnte nicht klappt
niemand weiß das ist es ein experiment
deshalb braucht es besondere
vorsichtsmaßnahmen man muss wirklich im
voraus moralisch überlegen wie man mit
dieser art von behandlung umgeht weil
man sie einem weg diese nachricht aus
den usa vielleicht erinnerungen an den
jüngsten fall aus china werden jeweils
zum science fiction darüber berichtet
der chinesische forscher jank louis von
der southern university of science and
technology hatte im vergangenen jahr
behauptet weltweit die ersten beiden
genmanipulierten babys erschaffen zu
haben dazu der wissenschaftler in einem
youtube-video zwei wunderschöne kleine
chinesische mädchen namens lulu und lana
kamen vor einigen wochen weinend und so
gesund wie jedes andere
zur welt er hatte das neue
allzweckwerkzeug der gentechnik dass
christa verfahren genutzt um die kinder
resistent gegen hiv zu machen
diese genmanipulation sorgten weltweit
für schlagzeilen nicht nur
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sondern auch regierungen weltweit
diskutierten darüber denn schließlich
ging es bei dem experiment in china
nicht darum eine krankheit zu behandeln
sondern um die optimierung eines
menschen china erließ daraufhin eine art
regelwerk für die anwendung der gen
scheren
die experimente von gm coo wurden
eingestellt der aktuelle fall in den usa
ist nicht wirklich vergleichbar denn
anders als im körper der chinesischen
babys befinden sich die genveränderung
der us krebspatienten nicht in allen
zellen ihres körpers die große
unkalkulierbare gefahr dass diese
änderungen also auch an nachkommen
weitergegeben werden besteht bei den
krebspatienten nicht doch auch wenn die
us forschungsteams versprechen alle
risiken sorgfältig abgewogen zu haben
besteht das große grundproblem weiterhin
die meisten menschen außerhalb der
wissenschaftswelt wissen zu wenig über
diese technik um ihr potenzial ihre
chancen um vor allem auch die risiken
abzuwägen wir müssen dringend
reflektieren welches risiko er eingehen
wollen und dabei auch an die
nachfolgenden generationen denken und
hier ist die politik gefragt denn im
medizinischen bereich herrscht bezüglich
der gehen schere eine art
goldgräberstimmung die abheben lässt
zudem fließen milliarden von forschungs-
und investitions geldern ein die die
euphorie noch größer werden lassen denn
wenn hier etwas schief geht können wir
die möglichen leiden für die patienten
patienten überhaupt nicht abschätzen so
verändern mal wieder was nach
experimenten in erster linie mit
whatsapp steigen wir jetzt für sichere
abos endgültig auf kilogramm um dort
könnt ihr nämlich so abonnieren dass ihr
garantiert kein video verpasst hier ist
der link dazu und dort bekommt ihr die
videos nicht nur früher soll man es gibt
diskussionsgruppen ihr könnt saved eben
vorschläge machen und vor allem bin ich
dabei zudem gehört es nicht zur facebook
datenkrake und man muss seine
telefonnummer auch nicht preisgeben wir
sehen uns hoffentlich auf touren bis da
weil wer hat das denn geschrieben also
also wirklich das kann man noch nicht
sagen also hallo